c'est un document exceptionnel sur la
guerre en ukraine que nous vous
proposons dans ce nouveau numéro de
reporter sur france 24 avec gwendoline
de bono nous allons découvrir le
quotidien des soldats du crânien sur le
champ de bataille des duels d'artillerie
de l'arrière jusqu'à ce qu'ils appellent
la position 0 la première tranche et
face aux russes vous allez découvrir les
combattants des brigades ukrainienne qui
tentent d'endiguer la progression des
troupes ennemies snipers artilleurs
fantassins ils se battent pour chaque
mètre de terrain et payent un lourd
tribut à la guerre gwendoline de gonnot
les a suivis sur le front du donbass
c'est un document france 24
[Musique]
sur le front ce soldat se bat contre ses
compatriotes
commandant d'une section parachutiste
ukrainienne camps d'al aqsa un
pseudonyme et russe donc parce qu'à
jamais dans ma vision des choses le
kremlin est un mâle universel s'est mis
tout le monde doit lutter contre
ces
voix là le champ il ya deux jours
c'était nickel et maintenant ils ont
brûlé une partie
ils cherchent ils n'ont pas encore assez
de repères ici et donc il cherche nos
positions ils essaient de nous atteindre
en tâtonnant
d'abord opposant à vladimir poutine en
russie il s'engage comme combattant en
ukraine en 2015 pourquoi la télé je vois
ce régime comme une tumeur qui
métastases sur le corps de notre planète
et chambre ici si tu regardes les
confits sur terre tu peux toujours
cherché à la main du kremlin
en russie je luttais contre le régime de
poutine autant que je pouvais
je participais à des actions je
diffusais des informations sur les
crimes du régime de poutine
magali chiche et ensuite j'ai compris
que l'avant poste de la lutte contre le
kremlin se trouvait en ukraine alors je
me suis rendu en ukraine
inlassablement son unité creuse pendant
que l'artillerie travail
dans cette guerre de position
pour survivre il faut sont terrés
les rotations dans la tranchée qui fait
face aux troupes russes dure trois jours
les soldes à l'appel la position 0
c'est très dur pour les nerfs
c'est vraiment une grande épreuve
as tu et à toi
je te demande si tu vas être à la
hauteur et dans telle ou telle situation
sous les bombardements
quand tu emmènes un blessé ou un mort ou
bien quand on te tire dessus
la première fois j'ai pensé que je
n'avais pas assez creusé qu'il faut
creuser plus encore plus pour protéger
la tête pouvoir mettre ses épaules
et j'ai pensé mon dieu j'ai aussi peu
vécu j'ai rien vu de la vie ensuite ça
m'est passé je me suis calmé n'y avait
pas de panique rien de tel
premiers blessés graves de la journée
pour la 25ème brigade aéroportée
les médecins militaires doivent
stabiliser ce soldat au plus vite son
chef de section est à ses côtés ça s'est
passé vers 10 heures mes combats tandis
que l'ennemi a d'abord tiré au mortier
ensuite ils ont corrigé le tir et un
char a commencé à tirer à partir d'une
position camoufler l'obus a touché ses
jambes et il a aussi reçu les fragments
dans le bas des jambes
[Musique]
les
corriger
on est sous le feu depuis minuit et ça a
duré 21h
depuis quatre jours c'est comme ça le
feu ennemi ces 21 heures sur 24
l'ennemi veut prendre d'assaut nos
positions et passer à l'offensive
[Musique]
les blessés légers retourne combattre
immédiatement d'autres choqué par le
blast d'un obus ne sont pas en état de
rejoindre le front
nous on a eu deux morts pas sur le coup
un mort en chemin la spécialité de notre
brigade c'est de nettoyer les villes pas
de rester assis dans une tranchée
[Musique]
dans le donbass les forêts protège
souvent les tranchées
presque indétectable dans la végétation
soap et price deux tireurs d'élite get
on a reçu l'info que dans cette zone
devaient se trouver un groupe de
saboteurs
on a reçu l'ordre d'avancer vers cette
zone forestière et de surveiller
une mission de routine pour le binôme
d'autres sont plus audacieuses comme ce
jour où ils sont envoyés derrière les
lignes ennemies près de la ville de
donetsk sous contrôle russe
on vient à moi nous avons dû entrer dans
un village temporairement occupé
six hommes ancrés dans la nuit nous nous
y sommes promenés pendant deux jours
parmi les russes
quand les troupes russes déplaçait dans
le village on leur tiraient dessus
depuis un endroit et puis on partait
vers un autre endroit on avait pris
assez de munitions
il en avait marre parce que leurs gammes
ou ray il ne comprenait pas d'où ça
venait le village était à eux mais leur
amour est quand même
j'aimais le fait de les voir paniquer le
premier jour ce jour là on en a tué 3 on
les voyait prendre des lits voler des
voitures il était en train de piller le
village
on a tué ses trois hommes pendant qu'ils
paient
ils ont très vite répondu avec de
l'artillerie n'importe comment pour nous
avoir sans même se préoccuper d'où
pouvait être leur zone ensuite des
snipers des bills sont arrivés ils ont
tiré avec des vieux fusil en dépit du
bon sens dans toutes les fenêtres on a
regardé on s'est déplacés et ça nous a
fait sourire
au milieu de la nuit toutes lumières
éteintes une section de la 95e brigade
aéroportée se prépare à rejoindre la
position 0 la première tranche et face
aux russes
un soldat près par les grenades elles
serviront si les troupes russes prennent
d'assaut la tranchée
oksana sniper dans l'unité et bogdan le
commandant prépare la rotation concentré
c'est moi qui établit les listes de ceux
qui sont envoyés là bas donc je porte
une responsabilité directe vis-à-vis de
chacun
maintenant la russie lance toutes ses
ressources disponibles dans la bataille
sérieusement on se bat pour chaque mètre
pour chaque mètre il faut comprendre
aussi que dans la logique de la russie
il ne peut pas se retirer sans une
victoire minimum sauf que le peuple
ukrainien n'admet pas la capitulation
donc c'est maintenant au sens premier du
terme notre guerre patriotique
ukrainienne c'est pour ça qu'elle va
durer
oksana et bogdan conduisent la section
vers le front
ces sommes vont devoir tenir leur ligne
sous le feu pendant 72 heures
une tâche harassante pour autant
personne ici ne veut entendre parler de
trêve encore moins de négociations
certains en europe pensent qu'il faut
c'est d'aider territoire ukrainien mais
je leur propose de commencer par donner
à la russie une partie de leur
territoire comme ça à l'avance pour
faire preuve de leur bonne volonté que
ce soit clair nous ne cédons pas nos
territoires si quelqu'un pense comme ça
soit il est complètement idiot soit
c'est un agent d'influencé russe
les bulles
au petit matin les soldats relevé dans
la nuit rentrer de la position 0
la fatigue ne semble pas entamer leur
humour
à peine l'armement ranger la section
débrief bogdan le coma
les chars ont avancé dans notre
direction sur la parcelle ils sont
passés des deux côtés de la parcelle
pour lancer leur infanterie
quentin des tanks commencé à tirer il
s'est pris une mine tout leur plan était
foutu
qu'est ce qui serait arrivé s'il était
passé on était cuit mais qu il aurait
envahi la parcelle avec un tel truc
ah oui on a tué un de leurs s'éclaira
rossi on l'a tué à bout portant cette
éclaireurs en paix sur ce champ de merde
les gars étaient en train de creuser les
tranchées ils se pointent un de nos gars
lui demande tu es qui n'ont tué 12 et le
type répond je suis de russie et la lega
lui ont tiré dessus
vous auriez dû lui faire passer un sale
interrogatoires et lui tirer dessus
après
non c'était plus intelligent de faire
comme ça
stanislav et oksana sont en couple ils
se sont rencontrés sur la place maïdan à
kiev en 2014
ils manifestaient alors pour une ukraine
libre est tournée vers l'europe
nous avons traversé mailles d'un
ensemble oksana été blessés sur la place
c'est moi aussi
ensuite lorsque la guerre a commencé en
2014 je me suis porté volontaire pour
combattre et depuis ce moment nous
traversons cela ensemble
quand la menace russe s'est accroché
nous avons pris la décision de rester
ensemble
12 c'est un très grand honneur de faire
la guerre pour une si belle nation qui
l'ukraine et je suis si fier que
maintenant les gens puissent vivre
tranquillement à kiev essentielle
paisible grâce à ceux qui sont ici au
front
c'est fou je me souviens tellement de
2014 l'excitation quand l'ancien
président pro russe ianoukovitch s'est
enfui
on avait gagné on allait devenir
européen plus de corruption plus de
flics qui torturent et merde on en est
là tout temps
huit ans plus tôt jaroslav aussi
manifesté sur la place maïdan 20
il est aujourd'hui officier d'artillerie
nous nous déplaçons vers une nouvelle
position
il faut comprendre où l'ennemi se trouve
par rapport à nous
sont les cibles intéressantes
quel est son armement il faut comprendre
beaucoup de choses pour pouvoir les
toucher
donc nous allons là bas pour avoir ces
éléments pour comprendre
plusieurs colonnes de fumée s'élèvent
autour de 7 les russes cible la zone
[Musique]
avant l'ordre de tir jaroslav et ses
pièces d'artillerie ne reste jamais au
même entre
[Musique]
l'ordre de tirer donné neuf heures plus
tard
les grades sont placés dans une
clairière position calculé par jaroslav
la veille
c'est un duel d'artillerie qui se joue
ici dans la campagne du donbass
[Applaudissements]
c'est la routine mais je suis un peu
nerveux quand on change de position il
ya toujours quelque chose de nouveau
et la position peut être une cible
tout près du but
jaroslav doit corriger son tir alors que
l'artillerie adverse se fait entendre
la cible est touchée après trois salves
de roquettes
les grades quitte alors la zone en
quelques secondes pour éviter la
réplique
jaroslav et son unité vont se mettre en
position ailleurs sur le feu
une mécanique qui ne sert qu'un seul but
pour le commandant ou espadrilles le
poète l'espadrille en ski a résumé
l'idée nationale de l'ukraine qui y est
foutez nous la paix
les ukrainiens sont des gens qui place
la liberté par dessus tout les
ukrainiens veulent vivre dans la merde
qu'ils en ont le droit
si nous voulons intégrer l'union
européenne
nous avons le droit de choisir cette
voie
c'est ça la liberté donnez nous la
possibilité de choisir ce qu'on veut
c'est pour ça que nous combattons
pour tous ceux qui sont au front il
s'agit avant tout de faire gagner à leur
pays son indépendance une bonne fois
pour toutes
et voilà pour ce document exceptionnel
signé gwendoline de bono c'est la fin de
ce magazine merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de reporter sur françois
[Musique]